ladies and gentlemen meet Joe Biden the
Science Guy of course just days ago the
science was telling by than that
Democratic convention which is still
months away may need to be cancelled
joining me now is Texas senator Ted Cruz
senator you felt this coming didn't you
not that this was going to be a keep
this going through the fall so we don't
have to have conventions probably not
even a campaign no debates and maybe not
even traditional voting it all has to be
done by mail well look i think biden is
terrified of the bernie brothers he
doesn't want to go to a democratic
convention because he's scared of the
activists because because that he knows
they don't want him and and you can see
i have you ever seen a presumptive
nominee hide from the american people
like joe biden is that this is it's
unprecedented well I've never seen
anything like it like it and I've never
seen anything like people concluding
many months out that things need to be
canceled or things need to be virtual
which means that they're not certainly
not as meaningful to folks it's just I
mean why do they feel like the need to
do that now but you get the sense that
the Democrats feel some of the fringe at
least feels like this is the only way to
ensure that they have a chance against
Trump to keep this thing going all the
way to the fall well I think they're
scared of whatever gaps what Biden might
say I I think they also you see the
media much of the mainstream media
trying to root for disaster there that
they're rooting for this pandemic to be
worse and worse and you saw you know the
the Washington Post self-proclaimed
fact-checker was was cheering about a
line from the State of the Union where
the president said we had the lowest
unemployment in 50 years and the
Washington Post was saying well gosh
that didn't stand up well to the test of
time well no you [ __ ] we had the lowest
african-american and Hispanic
unemployment ever recorded until a
global pandemic that originated in Wuhan
in China came and ended up causing
absolute chaos and get
tast Rafi but yet the media we should be
coming together to root for America to
root for defeating this pandemic and to
root for jobs coming back and I think
too many partisan Democrats want to just
use this catastrophe to attack Trump
rather than come together and fight for
our country senator here's what Biden
said yesterday about banning travel over
the virus well you know 45 nations had
already moved to keep blocked China's
personnel from being able to come in
United States before the president moved
so this is it's about pace it's about
it's about the urgency and I don't think
there's been enough of it
well that's a totally different tune
that he was singing back in January
watch this is no time for Donald Trump's
record of hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia - and fear-mongering to lead
the way instead of science no so why was
that bad science in January senator Cruz
but good science today
look it's just political opportunism you
know I spoke with President and Truong
upon February 2nd so a couple of days
after he put in place the the travel ban
to China and and president asked me at
the time said what do you think was it
the right thing to do he was getting
blasted by Joe Biden being called a
hysterical xenophobe the New York Times
was running editorials from op-ed
columnist blasting him for putting the
China ban in place I told him back then
mr. presidents exactly the right thing
it'll have real negative economic
consequences but this coronavirus is is
too dangerous and all of us need to do
what we can to protect people's lives
and safety and you know the CDC I
chaired a hearing on the corona virus
over a month ago the CDC said the
president's decision to halt air travel
in and out of China and to quarantine
any Americans coming back from China
substantially slowed the growth of this
virus in the United States and it
reduced the number of infections and it
saved lives in America and yet right now
Biden and Paulo
see and the press are all trying to
rewrite history to pretend they
supported what they criticized and
opposed at the time
senator Cruz Pelosi saying the next the
next the next bill will be a trillion
dollars now you're a fiscal hawk and I
think there are a lot of fiscal Hawks
that say they are but aren't really but
you are there's a lot of stuff she's
floating green new deal the green
infrastructure we got to get back to
work senator that's that's if we don't
get back to work who's gonna pay pay the
tab here look there there is no doubt we
have to get back to work we've got to
crises that are simultaneous we've got a
global pandemic that's a health crisis
at an economic I shouldn't ask that last
question thank you for being with us
come back soon we had the last bike
coming up next